you
all right this is a very good crew for a
created tournament 54 at the moment I've
entered call it 55 now three Oh blitz a
55-minute tournament
all right hand hand Hagen
opponent number one okay
well I could at least breathe
coming coming back from the bullet
tournament
mm-hmm
Oh castle
what do we want to do at my bishop I'm
going to put the bishop here and then
here and then I'll see what my c-pawn
wants to do
bishop here is threatening this because
of a pin so
oh I'm not going with that well let's
start by asking the bishop a question
and I am happy that I have a fly square
and I guess we just get this in right
now and a reason to be a bit more on the
aggressive side instead of defensive
with c6 is because there's a prize at
the end of the C file and that prize is
a tempo if the C file in fact opens up
but I do have an interesting option now
and that is to maybe acquire a three
versus two majority on the kingside yay
or nay to that
maybe I stay flexible for a moment for
just one more move I don't commit with
this poem of course my opponent could
ask me a question
yeah they just asked me a question all
right let's take oh really
I was not expecting that
well I guess if I take here the Queen's
gonna have a wonderful home I don't want
to give this home up to a queen or a
night expecting night here I can't take
because this bishop is a giant pest so
I'm prepared to get my Queen off of this
dog and I'll soon
how soon let's try like right now soon
in at least threaten the night you know
for this I have that and I think I still
have this right now
um yeah let's hop in this is a fork
there isn't a night move with check and
my night is ready to go into pac-man so
Queen takes our Knight takes Queen
Knight takes Bishop check so there's no
fancy knight move this is a losing
tonight takes Queen Bishop takes Queen
Knight takes Bishop check and then I
recapture in the end so the Queen moves
and in the end I should be picking up
some material now
I'm going to have a past C pun
yeah he needs to go
and now this guy
huh still interesting
my opponents going to find a good square
for the bishop I don't like that
I could um
maybe try something fancy like this
offer Queen exchange
I want to keep this poner on I don't
want to give this guy up and I want I
want to somehow force my opponent to
defend this pawn actually I don't know
that it can be defended and I always go
here I could build up
so this is a bad bishop but in it
protects some important pawns this is
more of a how to describe it it's a
position type where you just really want
to get your your major pieces working
well and
put pressure on weak points
I'm not that really wasn't said so well
should be thinking more about
well I'm not thinking so much about good
and bad bishops it's what I'm trying to
get out okay this is I think this is
winning
cuz I could do this if here I could just
push which it takes I take like that I
recapture and then here oh I didn't
realize my time
okay so it'll take like that and then
we're going here next this guy could
control that promotion square
so this is pushing through I think that
that was a best move can't be sure all
fancy and take here
very nice okay I could be patient though
I can also take that poem
I have a different angle to watch my
back ranks
my back ranks many ranks you have
you
brother this will be a painful one to
lose come on a pawn
can see let's go man
you
the rooks are cooked hook trucks
okay they resigned that wasn't the best
technique at all awful
okay interesting is in first
try to pronounce that we'll skip that
one taco done I don't know I don't have
explanations for why I laugh at certain
names Taco John next opponent okay we're
just gonna take some steps to make this
guy's life difficult
I'm not going to try to play with d4 so
d3 it is
these guys are trying to fight against
the unopposed bishop what's what's that
guy gonna do how is he going to see the
world serious strategic threat has been
ignored so if this pot ever moves these
guys become
well there's going to be a problem
isolated
you
okay just go here
I'm tactically vulnerable if I take
their so the only way to defend is night
here opening up to minors to defend but
the whole queenside is locked up this
night and pawn restrict
these two
and then I could insist Wow
so that about
it's getting a pretty crazy town I just
want to move the night so my queen has
some
some squares to work with
let's bring the Queen out it's important
I don't like allow this night to sit
here for even a moment
not come out this diagonal ever opens up
my night is conveniently defending v2
let's just ask the queen a question here
drops the rook may be tempting
if here I drop back okay the other miss
that
the rook is a goner
you
okay
just want to keep it squeaky clean clean
trades trade everything I think I just
want to go back here and then playoff
for I don't even want to allow Knight g3
okay so it opens up a little bit
I could take though
take again my queen will be there to
defend
okay my king belongs on h1 my queen
could safeguard my king like this
pieces are falling
you
okay
I'll take this phone no
let's just get my king here rook g1
I have these squares covered from the
checks
just want to double up now
okay
so more trades
and I guess we could go here
and then bishops III is Oh
the final move probably
Nomos for the king
he's trying to get on this diagonal
should be made in a few
all right they resigned where are we at
we're in fifth
we Faris X deep Trojan
Lazarillo the devious tomato this guy
just finished might be getting paired
with this guy
75 in here now 43 minutes to go see who
we get
somebody anybody 77 known here
you
nobody okay there we go we do have this
player now okay first I'm fine
let's try Sicilian
ah let's try a knight c6 okay open
Sicilian pawn on e5 square is weakened
take extra care of it okay a bit unusual
hmm okay let's let's kick this night
away for starters
and yeah I'm gonna play with b5 I don't
want to see this night easily wrote
relocate
I think this night must leave now
um
what's the issue if I take here probably
tactically vulnerable
somehow I'm just going to take care
yeah we'll bring the knight towards the
Kings side I have to watch out for these
sacrifices yeah
check we all check there's a bishop
block
how to do this Queen check
I'm losing a pond
how did I miss play this
you
don't hurt me
I might be getting hurt so
yeah I might be getting hurt very soon
this square is scary there's a check to
block I don't know I need two more moves
and then I'll be okay even if I didn't
maybe lose that pawn yeah my opponent is
bringing the pain trying to okay we
could be aggressive too maybe
see what this Bishop wants to do
give me g2 oh I really went into the
tank on that one
1:31 remaining Queen check I have a
block I have my base point covered with
a couple minors these guys can't be too
bad how would things be if there's an if
there is an ending that's interesting
okay let's get developing movin
if the bishop moves I have this even do
I be greedy I think so
defied greed this is a valuable pawn
clean here might be yeah what's the
story here I'm being cut out knight
Knight takes pawn King here
night here takes takes maybe there's
even that I don't have time to calculate
this stuff
you
maybe but the h-file opens up my bishop
was overloaded that's why I did this
it took forever to do
now I'm honest
and I think that this is a good
this is a good thing to do I want to
keep my rook around on the h-file I'm
gonna castle by hand I think I could go
for this I might have some mating ideas
a night here looks good but I think it's
out of play
so they try for this reposition I'm
under a minute
this is not good here just invites my
night to a wonderful square close to me
very close to me
let's go King
oh there's that move yeah you got a good
point
totally miss that one yeah I'm gonna be
down at least one phone very soon
I might need to use some
magic here on the clock
different upon this has gone wrong fast
even on the clock
I totally miss Bishop c7 yeah keep
pressure on something Oh God that's
painful oh that's really painful I'm not
even getting anything for it let's try
and mix it up
Oh God Oh God
I have to sack the farm
a good sign crawl up into a ball
can I survive
her oniy
okay we're going to have to give some
more material up
less than 10
could burn I could shave off a couple
seconds
might be I have a perpetual if I want it
but I'm going for the flag if it did
continue
oh man Bishop z7 was a backbreaker
[Music]
yeah
yeah I have to have to check out that
variation cuz that that was far from a
model game to say the least
hahaha okay Ferris X is in first deep
Trojan to our Menace three pendulum
swings next opponent
let's try efore Wow and there's still a
lot of time to go 36
okay let's try c3
make Lila proud make alpha0 proud put
upon on e5
game over okay what's this guy gonna do
that's this night's favorite square
all right we want to stop night before
I'm just doing this secure my bishop on
d3 okay let's go here force that maybe
and then we go here i punished trying to
get rid of their bad bishop
almost Castle he's defended this is
important as otherwise this is a tactic
I should be able to gain a tempo against
the Queen
at some point
develop here here who knows we would
know we'll go here
and okay
maybe I should have gone here yeah why
not okay
well my opponent is very underdeveloped
so
Wow
cannot be right
okay they resigned enough to I'd have to
find a move there are a lot of juicy
moves there nine G's six picks up
material I was looking at knight c6
before they resigned I takes c6 Queen
takes Bishop Knight takes bishop
something I didn't have to win material
in that one
to still have a good position that was
the other detail the C file I had a
straight line towards their king
I think things started to become a bit
awkward for black when they just
developed with Bishop e7 and also didn't
put any pressure on my d4 point
chess saga
usually Queen b6 happens in that one
French from the black side
yeah I played the exchange exchange
French and the bullet tournament what do
I want to do with this guy
fight for e5 or just prepare to be
pinned
to fend off a pin I'll be more
aggressive
mm-hmm
there ain't castles
alright let's see how this pin is
addressed
all right so some time has been wasted
I have simple moves
this is going to be kingside play
oh yeah I guess this is all right
I was thinking maybe I should have moved
my rook before Bishop to g6 but okay in
the end
what am i happy about I
have the better bishop
huh yeah but so what
where would I like to have my night I
don't know just want to maybe have some
major peace exchanges and still keep a
watchful eye over this square okay yeah
here's the other thing maybe I should
have moved this rug first okay we're
probably just gonna play with all minors
maybe we could still keep some pieces on
if I have this is a very nice structural
change because it combats the night and
gives Mike King a wonderful square so I
could I could think about maybe some
attack against the king
let's baby step it and after Russia
it's a very controlled position the
Knights under control this Knight is
not really bothering me
let's actually go here in case there's a
break I want to be prepared to camp out
on the d5 square okay now this is
winning the house actually
notice also because my queen isn't done
the same
rank is my rook there's no rook takes
Queen rook takes rook rook takes Queen
so I'm winning something big winning a
full row
I'll just take out the night
this is still not resolved
you
okay
I am up a full queen at the end of all
this
all right resins 16 1513 1294 in here
Phares X is in second Arminius third
Ryan McMackin fourth deep Trojan fifth
sack of sasquatches in there okay player
who I just never played before
okay let's try a scotch
Petra
okay scotch
you
all righty
hmm okay
this-this-this
not d6 though
okay he doesn't have a better square
than seed three I want to this is one of
the cases where I do follow the nights
before Bishop's rule
well this is the least flexible piece of
the three minors so okay how do I want a
complete development I probably want to
go queenside
and I'm going to go here this pin is
short-lived it's just broken
to h6 Bishop Ani its e3 is vulnerable to
Knight g4 I think I don't know where
this Bishop belongs so I think I'm gonna
gear up for Queen d2 queenside castle
maybe this
I'm going to place an emphasis on peace
play first
Queen d2 queenside castle
also if my bishop is placed here this
idea to Castle queenside could run into
some tempo gainers I'll go straight in
for it
so pretty much have to go in this
direction all right is do we just carry
on with this idea everything that I'm
saying I'm going to do I'm going to do
let's get on with it
now if beef or do I really jump in
I think I think I want to when I play g5
I want this night to struggle so I'm
gonna go here and even here maybe and
then this is starting become awkward for
the night
I want to control f6 ok what's the story
with that ok so you ready to kick my
knight and then take here and also go
there if I do that there's that
okay well I'm still gonna go here with
the idea of meeting c5 with a chop and
then there's a lot of pawns on dark
squares this unopposed Bishop is I don't
see how it gets active too fast so I
have to do this otherwise I'm losing
that I have a square to work with that's
no good because I went up on
so they might be ready to make a mistake
have to take you how to take care right
they're in the tank the pink tank okay
hop in
okay so
trade no I'm okay if
[Music]
you
I'll initiate the exchange I don't like
the idea of having two pieces on this
diagonal
I'll force one of the pieces to back up
and then in the end I'm taking here also
this pawn may drop yeah so I'm hitting
some stuff okay I'm going to I'm going
to grab this pawn
be careful
I could get out of this pin
two moves okay
but a mouse them let's go here
past a pond
you
it's uncomfortable to defend this you
know
the bishop control some dark squares
stop Bishop here as well and I should be
okay with grabbing upon this is
significant
and my knight has a wonderful square I
will I will take care
[Music]
yeah
hmm
okay this guy he's still around
defend and I want to see the bishop get
on this diagonal
I also had that let's push many ways to
do it
put my king here at night somewhere good
very nice improving moves for my night
there way down on time they resigned
okay 25 minutes to go I am NOT in first
Skye is in all-out berserk mode 3 3 5 5
5 21 with fire see in a game he's in a
game top two are playing right now 19:31
having a very good performance
Chris p99 next opponent what do we do
let's try a center counter a
Scandinavian defense
okay
just going with something ultra solid
white nothing
yeah why does retaining the option to
play with c4 or maybe I should have done
that I'll do this now
because a queen on b3
I'll go here Queen ob3 I want to play
here maybe here okay one is going to
gain a tempo I could take that pawn
though right
unprotected
let's go opposite the Queen for starters
okay like Queen is snug
cleanin c7 connect Knights
I'm not thinking anything anything more
complete development play within this
structure
let's let's maybe play with a five now
one of the reasons why I went with this
rook instead of this one because of this
a5 idea and now I'm winning a poem that
was on that twice
killer bees
can I put some more pressure here let's
react with a punch
and what's the story here if I play
Queen here
hm
so with this keep an eye on that flight
square might be some back ranked issues
here
to be careful of this bishop how would I
defend this pawn I could go here
breaking in the center all right this
gives up a square lets make use of it
f2 could be sensitive queen g6 if my
bishops on this diagonal
on an f7 pinned
the Queen finds it a bit difficult to
find a square okay I have the bishop
pair I'll be recapturing with a pawn I
want to control this Knight
okay do I have something fancy
here
I don't quite have the pieces around I
really want to take that I think I could
it's unnecessary
to win upon
let's go for the win over Palmer
and we're going to improve the night
clean here here is close to being trap
now
this pawn is pinned I don't know how I
could really take advantage of it though
hmm
you
back rank I still need a flight square
but I have enough support for it
why did I go there light f4 is pretty
pretty good isn't it
hmm
oh wow
alright go for a queen exchange I'll
keep up I'll keep my knight around
okay
we're taking them let's get the flight
square in
you
finally a rook is off
right there yeah
well this should be a draw
should
how do you try to win I'm gonna try to
win by exchanging off this problem this
is this is a nice move to see
let's try and cut the King off I want to
get in each four okay that shot down hmm
I'm playing this with an eye on the
clock
you
Brook is there to defend
you
I want to step up a rink
I want to secure my king okay they've
been they miss played it and I'm getting
this pawn threatening me threatening me
now stalemates yeah mate next
just a quick note with this one these
are the these are irrelevant ranks this
trick should be back on one of the this
one or this one
secure the king position put the rook
there I think is a more purposeful
diagonal more purposeful rank
okay we're under 20 over a hundred are
in here now
25:24 I'm one point out from first place
and there are a couple on my heels
all right
keep going
a mover
all right let's try Bishop g5
hmmm here I could play you for no what
am I talking about
it's thinking I have some fools may I'd
be the fool imagine that g5 e4 pawn
takes Bishop and I just put my Queen
here
don't check no game over yeah that would
be brilliant
I could have also just captured in reply
to h6
all right so it's it started out like a
trump Hobbs skiing but we're in Queens
Queens gambit declined territory
okay that's a big hole that one is too
works
clean us to go here yes
and here I could do this
I'm going to play like this though I
want to keep this square
open so I could go here
just fitting my pieces right behind my
structure as all
okay now we're gonna ask the knight of
quite or should we do that yeah build
the center Oh No
this pawn could have been captured for a
couple Mouse I forgot my bishop is
masked we're getting that that tension
is still there so on Knight takes okay
now they're taking like that
hmm okay I will take care
this could be kind of tricky to defend
now one two three four and there's only
three defenders of the f5 square how is
it defended some kind of counter
attacking stuff mm-hmm
but
let's just go here
you
it could take
they got recaptured the okay I just go
for a pond win now yeah this is covered
there isn't some mate so I I could take
on e6 okay now probably no I think I
like taking with the bishop
I'm on the night I have some checks
possibly
maybe night here
could also advance this pond what would
be the downside with that I don't see it
this is weakened
but tough tough to get at that thing I
keep pushing
yeah
okay now this Bishop's going to be shut
out
take care
how do I keep this squeaky-clean I could
insert a check
even on the clock
hmmm let's step up what's my queen
actually I'm fearful of a rook exchange
and then a queen check on e3
also stops this activity okay now there
should be a problem because of this
check now the king is going to get lured
out
has to go here to keep the repented
so I should have checks here here let's
see if I could control some squares this
rook definitely belongs here for
starters
The Roommate my queen could get here my
bishop could get here with check I'll be
able to control these squares my queen
is going to be able to arrive on this
square this should be a backbreaker
queen here I don't have this square the
Queen's covering it but I do have this
one Queen here and a bishop on f5 will
control
I think this is mating or my pun asked
to give up the Queen has to give up the
Queen no it's actually meaning
I'm better
check queen takes bishop maybe I go here
probably resign
check bishop hasta block takes king us
to go here take a rope
and I'll see the mate
you
no good defense here okay they resigned
thirties in first this guy is almost in
an all-out berserk thirty with fire
twenty-eight see in a game he's in a
game and he's berserk again and maybe
losing pom takes
I do feel he's running for his life
lucifer get him
okay 106 in here
apples
eles mmm
now we didn't play in this tournament
kd5 it is okay he's not going to be
aggressive
you
let's let's go back I don't want to I
don't want to take
I play c5 there's eight three I want to
keep the Bishop around
so let's see symmetrical structure
our nights are a little bit weird both
will be connected soon
yeah we're probably going to reorganize
our clean in a similar way mm-hmm
I'll go for this - I think my threat
will be more
potin because i have a night here that
masks this pressure on g7 but the
corresponding g2 square doesn't have
that support so now i'm threatening this
and then rip the heart out
Kano
so if takes on this square maybe I did
this too early I should have invested a
move with this yeah I think they could
have captured here if I take with the
night then I lose upon if I take with
the pawn these guys are blocked so now
there's some dark square weaknesses
I'm going to invest the fly square at
this stage and keep the tension
I want to sneak in one more move here I
think I want to initiate some exchanges
now in the center so this night could be
unprotected in a move
maybe I could start focusing on the dark
squares now yeah let's let's do this we
open up the rook
not this square quite yet but I think my
queen wants to go elsewhere now she did
her job she had some influence on these
moves so with all pieces still on the
board this is not so healthiest
structure
and I feel like I should be trying to
slice in on the dark square so we'll go
with this
Bishop check and then here stuff comes
to mind let's just insert the check and
then flush this night out of my house
I'm gonna sneak in see what happens
I'd love to switch the order my queen
and Bishop it would take forever
this was foolish
this was - this was not right
you
there is something better there I should
not have moved my night to h5 maybe
maybe build up some more
okay I'm actually tempted to return from
being honest
or-or-or let's actually just take and
make sure this diagonal stays open okay
so I really need to keep my eyes peeled
for some tactic
I can still improve though
now I can find some square drop in at
any moment this night can't move
let's get this replying pone is under a
minute
mmm-hmm now the time to hop in
you
do I have the time too
you
I'll happen no no I could have
considered with the clean but no okay
there's night there
all right where do I want my oh my queen
has a moment now to slither on over
there's that
okay and pull that move off my other
night might also visit the h5 square
these dark squares are extra appealing
back and then here like I was saying
reverse the order the Queen and Bishop
I don't care about this poem I'm looking
for an attack
Oh actually I win some I win a night
that's the other detail
when takes pawn bishop back up for this
defend the pond we're setting up
Discovery's
should have some me
rook here
no way to stop the rooks influence on
the second
mate soon
okay down on time 35 32 oh he didn't he
didn't lose that game he somehow managed
to win
how's that game looking it's looking
like a draw
he didn't preserve that one seven
minutes Wow
Hagen
alright one more game at least maybe two
not going to berserk the next one
especially if I get paired up with hand
Hagen it doesn't make sense to
okay let's try an e for game
all righty scotch
okay
let's try NATO five
you
that's a move isn't it whoa ultra
defensive
Bishop's getting quite a workout
I want to move that night because this
guy wants to see the world
I want this bishop
probably on c4 I don't plan on castling
queenside like I did in the in the one
game especially with this Bishop
pointing right at on that side of the
board
let's just go Kings side same sides
castles most likely
and now that let's fight for this square
a little bit Parliament has a couple
pieces there and also this move now hits
with tempo
f-for
let's start with this I think my
opponent may go for that movie yo let's
take
okay and now I could go to I have to be
very careful actually here takes takes
f4 but I'll be able to get an e5
now there's knight c6 then hmm maybe I
have to start with that for
I'll start with that for I don't want to
see that Pony yet enough for because
then
I don't know trying to defend or always
keep a watchful eye over this f3 move so
we'll both have two pawns guarding our
Kings but this is a cozier home for my
king their setback
ah man I can't take
this was not calculated I have this move
oh I don't yeah I do if the Queen moves
I could take here oh boy oh boy I'm in
trouble
oh wow am I really lucky that this is
working out Bishop takes Queen takes and
it's there's still a pin Oh sometimes
better to be lucky than good that's not
how the saying goes
yeah really lucked out with this
sequence
we're gonna get this game in
3:33 mm-hmm it's not over yet okay I
think I have to do this
Challenge this night otherwise I'm going
to be in another annoying pin
can I just save the piece it remains to
be seen
okay the piece is saved this pawn is
gonna go down though maybe Queen here
hit the bishop hit everything break down
the light squares at some point have
five let's be on the lookout for f5
let's be on the lookout for this
hmm
ah yeah
okay let's go here and pig force the
Queen's off it's probably a good idea no
I'm not going for that all right let's
go opposite the king and drop a pawn at
the same time how they don't want it
alright let's push mm-hmm hang on oh
hang on hang on hang on triple pawns
triple bonds
hang up.we give a check around
you
let's go on this pivot here
straighten out my pawns there we go
take here I have this should be a
backbreaker
you
this guy okay let's go here keep
pressure on something
I'm oh I can't do that okay let's give
it check all right we're gonna have to
try this ending
you
should be good for me
King position
Oh
[Music]
let go too
check just want to flush the King away
I'm gonna step up Oh stopping now
can a pawn break in
making progress and new files open up
hang up now we're going to get upon
now we could get running
Khan is not going to be stopped
at a mate threat they resigned and
that's gonna be it yeah like I even want
another game Wow very nice showing this
guy no this is the one I just played and
that's how it's going to end 44 36 35 29
108 and all
I don't think it's going to change much
we'll wait these next 25 I haven't been
staring at the twitch chat
you
horse become er I see in the chat furry
fries on Twitch
blitz lobbies is in the chat is well
Alexandre four seven five seven and many
others that I cannot get to okay this
one is officially over two
okay let's see all the pages
all the participants chess web fog of
chess
Coolio pinteresting crispy deep Trojan
Leon Almighty for its grant
you
you
let's see
Raichle - alright that's everybody
to the 107 of you good games
you